Alcaide: For me, to be
up on the silks is freedom.
Finally I can fly.
This is the only moment that
I can leave my brain empty.
[funky music]
This kind of exercise
is not about strength.
It's about confidence.
Confidence is what we use
to help hearing people
communicate with deaf people.
Deaf people has no
communication barriers.
We put the barriers for them.
So we need to create
a more inclusive world.
Everybody is the same.
We are only people.
Manel is also the co-founder
and CEO of Visualfy,
an app that translates sounds
into visual and sensory alerts.
Manel Alcaide.
Acrobat.
App maker.
Celebrating app makers
worldwide
Share your #IMakeApps story
g.co/play/imakeapps